Щойно лікарі зупинили серце пацієнту, аби потім знову його запустити.
Це Інститут серця у Києві. Сьогодні у медиків надскладне завдання -
вони  імплантують 46-річному чоловіку штучний серцевий клапан.
Зараз накладаємо шви і потім імплантуємо механічний протез в артальну позицію.
Для операцій такого рівня потрібно світло без вимкнень, а саме слово "блекаут"
звучить - як вирок. Адже усе в операційній, починаючи від апарату штучного кровообігу,
апаратів УЗД, різноманітних датчиків і закінчуючи операційними лампами,
працює на електриці. Раптове зникнення електроенергії
може призвести до летального наслідку.
Інституту серця планові відключення електрики не стосуються,
оскільки це об'єкт критичної інфраструктури. Втім, лікарня все одно має
і кілька генераторів на випадок повного знеструмлення.
Ми маємо зараз 5 генераторів на нашій території, які живлять службу крові,
живлять реанімацію окремо, окремо операційну, наше відділення,
які потребують електрики постійно.
Ми маємо автономну службу опалення зараз. Ми перейшли на опалення
щепою дерев’яною і маємо свою скважину.
Ми можемо існувати деякий час, може, декілька тижнів.
Якщо це буде дуже довгий період, ми маємо план Б - евакуацію.
Самі ж лікарі готові працювати й у повній темряві, маючи лише ліхтарики.
У нас є на випадок, коли все відключиться, навіть такі ліхтарики -
це якщо буде відключення всього. Більш того, якщо вийде з ладу навіть акумулятор,
то є руки: руками ми можемо дихати, руками ми можемо крутити апарат
штучного кровообігу і це вже було. Хворий від цього не страждає.
Олег Анатолійович - анестезіолог з 30-річним досвідом. 2-3 операції на добу,
кожна тривалістю від 2-х до 4-х годин - норма для нього.
На рік це 100, 120 операцій зі штучним кровообігом.
Після початку повномасштабного російського вторгнення в Україну
в лікарні побільшало пацієнтів. Поряд із цивільними лікарі рятують життя
й українським військовим.
Це було для нас нове - такі тяжкі поранення. Мінно-вибухова травма,
осколкові поранення серця, ураження коронарних судин.
Зараз ви станете свідком, як зупинене серце знову почне працювати.
Для кардіохірурга робота в цій операційній вже закінчилась, його чекають у наступній.
А тут інші медики продовжують свою роботу,
адже запуск серця - не останній етап операції.
Зараз зупиняємо апарати штучного кровообігу, будемо "зашиватись",
будемо закінчувати операцію.
Постійно на роботі. Ми були постійно на роботі. Перші 2-3 місяці (війни) ми були
постійно на роботі всі. Зараз ми трошки вже вийшли на більш-менш планову роботу.
Ми переглянули свої життєві цінності: що для нас раніше було цінне.
Зараз для нас цінне життя. І допомога один одному. Це найважливіше в даний час.
Лікарі завершують операцію, пацієнта ж направляють в реанімацію,
де він проведе декілька днів під наглядом лікарів та медсестер, таких як Катя.
На даний момент у нас у великому реанімаційному залі 8 пацієнтів
і на всіх 8 пацієнтів працює тільки 3 медсестри.
Люди стали більше хворіти на серцеві хвороби.
У нас можуть бути пацієнти як і на ШВЛ, так і такі, що можуть самостійно дихати.
Потрібно швидко переключатись на генератори. Потрібно розуміти, що робити.
Це тяжко не тільки морально, фізично. Я б сказала, що морально тяжче.
Попри втому і повітряні тривоги лікарі та медсестри продовжують працювати.
Вони вірять: українське серце не зупинити і "блекаут" вдасться уникнути.